one of the other great quarterbacks in
football who when you look at his
statistics for this season you would
think he's playing this weekend but his
team was four and 12 despite desean
watson having one of the great seasons
of any quarterback in the nfl this year
he posted a tweet today and look we have
to consider everything he says within
the context of what's happening everyone
knows there's an issue between him and
the texans everyone knows he's inclined
to get out of houston he tweets today
i've been trying to have some patience i
told my mama she should pray on it and
my first thought was gee you know people
are gonna say this is a song lyric and
it turns out that it is it's from
it's from uh a future song uh codeine
crazy i believe is the name of the song
although that's not my age group by any
means but i had some younger reporters
reach out to me and tell me that's
exactly what it was but still miles it
would be naive
given how big of a deal this is for
people to not look at that and say yeah
it's lyrics from a future song but at
the same time
he knows and we know what's going on and
i looked at that as just the latest just
the latest little piece of evidence just
the latest little thing that adds a
little more heat to a hot situation in
houston
oh yeah for sure i think anytime
somebody's tweeting out song lyrics
there's a purpose to it it's like when a
decade and a half ago when everybody had
myspace pages and you would put your
song on there you know it was to say oh
this is my mood right now i'm really
really happy you know my boyfriend just
did something really nice for me or i'm
really angry because somebody just broke
up with me it's the same sort of thing i
think when you've got guys now tweeting
out song lyrics and whatever it is that
they are they have some sort of purpose
behind them i don't think anything like
this in this social media age where
everybody is online everybody's got
instagram everybody's got twitter
everybody's doing snapchat most people
now even have tick tock everything has a
purpose once you reach a certain level
of celebrity so i don't understand
exactly what the connection is with
future that he seems to have because the
i was on two then i took it to a ten
that also was uh future song lyric two
so
it's interesting to me that desean
watson just loves to quote future but
there has to be some sort of thing
that's also behind it because nothing is
just benign these days
and this comes one day miles after
the texans interviewed eric the enemy
they got a special dispensation from the
league permission from the chiefs to
talk to eric the enemy before the
chief's playoff run ends because the
texans had failed during the kansas city
bye week to interview like eric banemy
like every other team did except for the
eagles who presumably will be able to
interview him as well they got to the
party a little bit late they have a
different reason for not interviewing
eric the enemy the first week after the
regular season ended
is that
enough i and i i wonder with the tweet
today
you know is desean watson as skeptical
as i am and you may be about whether or
not they're just interviewing eric b
enemy to placate deshaun watson i
reported over the weekend that desean
watson also recommended that robert sala
be interviewed and he was completely
ignored on that one they didn't make a
request at any time to talk to robert
sala before or after the first week of
the process i think
deshaun waston is or at least should be
skeptical about what's going on and i
think that tweet has something to do
with expressing his current state of
mind his current skepticism about
whether or not the texans really are
trying to fix this and if so are they
going about it the right way
yeah for sure and look i think it's
interesting that eric the enemy would
even accept the interview in the first
place after what was going on on there
if you know if you don't
if if the chiefs have a bye week and
everybody is able to interview this guy
and you don't do that at that time what
exactly are you doing and so i think
that should certainly factor into it um
but when it comes to desean watson and
whether he's placated enough by this i
don't know that it would make me feel
that placated just because oh now you're
deciding that okay now it's really a
problem and now you should actually do
something that i recommended to you even
though sensibly the best quarterback
that most people have ever seen in their
lifetime has said i recommend this guy
this guy is somebody that has helped me
in my career and so now that's something
that can maybe help you in your career
as well so the other thing that i just
kind of thought was interesting is you
know if er you're eric the enemy
why did you not just tell them to kick
rocks because that is something that i
might have done even though obviously
there's only 32 of these jobs and only a
certain amount of them come open every
single year but i don't know mike were
you surprised that the enemy didn't just
tell the texans to kick rocks
yes but also miles
you go into this now with some power
they need you if they want to salvage
their relationship with desean watson
they've got to come get you that means
you can ask for a little more money you
can ask for a little more security you
can get one of these six-year deals that
the dysfunctional teams seem to now have
to give out in order to convince people
to go work there but for the enemy i
said this earlier today with sims on pft
live i would want to budget up to two
hours me with deshawn watson on one in a
room and it may not take two hours it
may take five minutes i want to know if
i put my name on the bottom of that
contract is that going to be enough for
you to be all in are you my guy are you
here or are we going to be doing this
dance throughout this first offseason
because i'm not taking this job desean
if i think you're not going to want to
be fully committed to being the
quarterback of my football team
yeah for sure because otherwise why
would you not stay in kansas city
continue to perhaps win super bowls with
patrick mahomes until the perfect
situation comes up because right now if
you're eric the enemy despite not
getting that many looks i guess we could
say in this particular coaching cycle
you're always going to be a hot
candidate as long as you're working with
patrick mahomes and you're working with
that offense and that offense is as
productive as it continues to be so if
this is not the right fit if this is not
the perfect fit and if desean watson
isn't saying yes if you come here i'm
here with you and we're all in on this
then i don't think that that's a perfect
fit for eric the enemy
you know the other thing too miles and
this may be a reason why eric b enemy
didn't say no
the nfl is a very unique industry it's
32 billion businesses most of which are
run by monarchies and if you get in the
business of pissing off sorry london
one you may have trouble getting your
foot in the door with others i mean look
what josh mcdaniels is dealing with
three years after he spurned the cults
he's having a hard time generating real
interest and now the eagles are
interested because what the hell else
are the eagles going to do frankly
they've got a job that's almost as
undesirable right now as the texans job
but i think there's something to that
even if you don't take the job going
through the courtesy of sitting for the
interview of playing the game that is
something that that i think was smart
for the enemy to do because you don't
want other owners to hold that against
you next year
yeah that's true and when you think
about it that way it's also the the
thing of oh well if i get into this
interview and no matter what i'm gonna
do then i'll probably have a better
interview the next time and whether it's
a fit or not because not every job is a
fit for everybody or every coach
but if you get into that interview you
say what you need to say you find out
what you need to find out maybe you
actually end up thinking it's better
than you might have thought it would be
coming in or you figure that okay yeah
it's actually exactly what i thought so
i don't know i think what you're saying
about it being the gatekeepers and all
that that probably is true too so it
does behoove him whenever he gets the
opportunity to then take up that
opportunity and take it seriously
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports